hi my name is Jen and we're having a
fortune cookie show I can bring home the
bacon so what's the real reason behind
Jen Garner's instafamous pretend cooking
show boys had a love of cookie but I've
always also had a love of cooking shows
but Jen says she has no plans to star in
her own cooking show she's happy just
playing around on Instagram what would
you say is your specialty dish oh I
don't think I have one I mess up about
50% of what I cook
I probably bake homemade bread the most
often oh I saw when it a turtle these
are like the kids want a turtle right
they blended a turtle I really want you
to be my mom Jen honey I feel like it
would be so fun and I bet you're the
person who in school lunches that you
like cut them into shapes and put an
omiai oats sometimes sometimes not we
teamed up with Jen and Walmart to help
inspire meaningful connections for food
why do you think Jen no pressure she's
sitting right beside you is the perfect
ambassador for this program she's a
foodie she knows a lot about food she
knows her stuff food and cooking are at
the center of every gathering and there
is no one who has more sustainably
sourced organic better priced fruits and
vegetables produce and goodies and
Walmart tell me about the community
table so the community table is a way
for people to be inspired online and
then they can post their favorite family
recipes it was just a way of connecting
people through
and nobody is better equipped to do that
no mama